in the last video I talked about how
both Ben's shoes and Jason's shoes are
fundamentally the same business but they
have different capital structures and
the way we saw that is that they they're
everything their revenue gross profit
all the way down to their operating
profit was exactly the same they're
generating the same economics from the
operating part of their differ of their
business but because they have different
capital structures what happens below
that line was a little different in
particular you saw interest expense on
Jason's business and not on Ben's income
statement so let's look at what that
means so if you look at both of these
guys assets so this down here this is
kind of their balance sheet you see that
they're the same they both have $20,000
in cash and I've drawn it over here this
is Ben's assets $20,000 in cash $20,000
in cash they both have $100,000 in
inventory and I've made I've made the
height proportional to how many dollars
we're talking about so they both have a
larger amount of inventory and then they
both have $20,000 we do that in that
same color and they both have $20,000 of
equipment $20,000 of equipment so their
assets are the same the things that are
actually generating the revenue and the
profit are the exact same thing we're
assuming that they're also renting in
very similar locations that's what they
would have to happen for them to have
such similar economics now what's
different about them is what happens on
the other side of the balance sheet and
this is what I meant by them having
different capital structures so let me
draw the liabilities side for both of
these characters so let's do liabilities
liabilities there and liabilities over
here now they both have the same amount
of accounts payables may be the people
they're buying shoes from they're able
to delay paying their those those super
just is a little bit so by a few months
or a few weeks or whatever so they owe
those vendors some money so they both
have $5,000 in in accounts payables let
me do that I'll do that in pink so they
both have $5,000 I'll try to do it
proportional to the size so that right
over there that is the accounts payable
the $5,000 they both have that on the
liability side now where they really
diverge so this is the same amount
$5,000
it should be about 1/4 of the side it's
not exact the way I've drawn it but
where they really diverge is that Jason
Jason over here let me do this in an
appropriate color Jason over here has
$100,000 in debt and Ben has no debt so
in his liabilities he also has $100,000
he also has $100,000 in debt so this is
the debt right over here $100,000 and
then doesn't have it so the way the way
you can think about capital structures
they have the same assets capital
structure tells you how did they pay for
that asset that they take it with debt
are they deferring payments to the sum
of their vendors or do they have equity
and we could see whatever is left over
remember owner's equity is assets minus
liabilities so what we have left over
here is the owner's equity so they both
had $135,000 in assets you subtract out
the hundred and five thousand dollars of
liabilities for Jason he has 35 K of
equity $35,000 of owner's equity on
Ben's side he has much more so he kind
of paid more of this or more of the
capital structures equity here more of
it is debt but if you have 135 or
$140,000 in assets you have $5,000
liability here he has 135 thousand
dollars in equity so when we talk about
capital structure we're saying how are
we funding the assets and not only do we
talk about the composition between
between lot between debt and equity
we're also talking about how the equity
is composed and we can see in both of
these their equity is split into 10,000
shares so each of those shares would be
110 thousand of the just the equity
piece so you split that into 10,000 or
you could split this right here into
10,000